good morning John yesterday I said that
we're gonna talk about it once of stuff
that we're not gonna talk about all
that's goin team right out the window
because there's something much more
important going on now I need you to
find balloons a little bit of background
on that DARPA which is like the research
arm of the US military they are the ones
who created the Internet
yeah Internet is putting up ten large
eight feet across weather balloons
across the United States and the first
person to locate and submit all ten
locations of all ten balloons will get
40,000 dollars so I was thinking about
the project for awesome and I was
thinking you know would make the project
for awesome just a little bit more
awesome and $40,000 was my exact answer
I was also thinking that John you and I
and the nerdfighters and YouTube are
extremely good at being a tight-knit
community that is very geographically
disparate which is not something that a
lot of other communities are good at
being so I was thinking this is a pretty
amazing chance to prove our awesome and
make the project for awesome awesome ER
and I got really excited and now we have
planned the whole thing I'm warning you
it is surprisingly complicated I would
like to ask nerdfighteria and all the
members of the global YouTube community
to help with this for people who are one
in the continental United States to have
a car three have a cell phone you all
have cell phones why did I even put that
in for our free on Saturday I would like
you all to join the search discover and
confirm team if you're cool with that if
you cool the search discover and confirm
team needs to do two things one I need
you to send an email to DARPA nerd at
gmail.com that email must be titled a
search team please spell it correctly
that email us to include your name your
city your state and if you want your
neighborhood also this is not necessary
but we would very much appreciate it if
you would include your phone number so
we can contact you at a moment's notice
second I need you to go to nerdfighters
comm and on the left-hand side of the
page there will be a little sign up box
asking you to sign up for the team all
you have to do is put your email address
in there and confirm and I promise we
will never send you emails about
anything except for the balloon project
I promise the reason why we need to do
this is because we expect there to be
lots of misinformation around and
because we expect that misinformation
we're going to need members of our
community to be able to at a moment's
this go and check on a nearby balloon to
make sure that it is a DARPA balloon and
that it is where people said it was now
it also request that you go out and look
for yourselves and try and find the
balloons everyone else those of you who
are not in America don't have cars
aren't free on Saturday I have some very
important jobs for you too but in order
to find out what they are you have to
sign up for that mailing list that I
just mentioned it is on the left hand
side of nerdfighters calm if you think
that you have found a balloon either
because you asked your friends and
family to tell you if they saw a balloon
and they said that they did or because
you saw one please either call us at the
number below I would appreciate it if
you would put this in your cell phone
right now this number here it's actually
six six oh six nine dftba someone will
either answer that phone or you can
leave a message you can also text
message that number or send us an email
at DARPA nerd at gmail.com the
information in your email text message
or phone message must include a street
address or Street intersection of nearby
where the balloon is the number of the
balloon it does not count if we don't
have the number and hopefully your name
so that we can say thanks the balloons
are going up all across the country at
10 o'clock Eastern Time that means 7
o'clock Pacific and they will go down at
4:00 p.m. here's what the balloons look
like please don't forget that they're
going to be lots of teams playing this
for profit and they will do anything to
get it the information that we have so
it's very important that we keep it a
secret if we know where a balloon is if
we can get the $40,000 we will be giving
all of it to the charities promotive and
the best project for awesome videos this
year nobody else has a team like we have
a team this is going to be amazing